We have a voicemail number and that
number is a two one nine two David Pakman.
Now, I am I'm glad to be corrected
on this program. I love it.
On the bonus show the other day, Pat and I
discussed the idea of vaccination sticker's,
a sticker that says you've been vaccinated. And we
talked about the possible positive impact of that,
including that it would create sort of like
a public movement to encourage others to be
vaccinated. But I heard from a bunch of people
with a very different view. And clearly,
this is the privilege I have of living in a blue
area. Folks who live in red areas have written in
saying those stickers could get you attacked. And
the man who lives in a rural red upstate New York
wrote in a rather called in and said exactly
that. Take a listen to what he had to say.
Hi, Dave and Pat, I'd like to respectfully
disagree with your opinion on wearing the I
got vaccinated stickers. Yeah, I live in an area
that is so red that if I went around with an I got
vaccinated, right. I might get assaulted. I'm not
even kidding with you. I actually gave blood this
morning and the nurse who took my blood told me
I would never get that vaccine is horrible. It's
not tested. She literally mentioned right wing
talking points that I heard Trump say all the
time. Conspiracy stuff I'd be afraid to wear. I
got vaccinated sticker the same way as I'm afraid
to put it. I voted for Joe Biden sticker on my
car in the area that I live. Thank you. So, yes.
All right. Shalom as well to it. To Eckmann,
peace and love. He's right. And I think maybe
Pat and I were a little bit anxious on the
trigger of saying this would be a great idea,
because there are people in many parts of the
country who may not so easily be able to just
walk around with their I'm vaccinated sticker.
It could actually cause them problems. So let's
continue to think about it and think about the
right way to sort of publicly encourage folks to
get vaccinated. But I think the yagman brings up
a very good point. We've got a great bonus show
for you today. The Swedish king, Carl the 16th.
Gustaaf says that the coronavirus approach in
Sweden is not gone so well. We will talk about
the possible return of the Iran nuclear deal.
We will talk about an important Supreme
Court decision that may be coming soon,
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at join Pakman Dotcom.